kommen
ich bin dort stammte und auch ich möchte
allen danken der ganzen welt danken was
sie für meine familie getan haben vor
allem führt dort die welt kennt
[Applaus]
wir haben ihn alle geliebt und ich
möchte allen müttern der banken die
heute hier sind seinem neffen seinem
onkel gibt ihnen eine umarmung und lasst
sie wissen all die jungen männer die
jetzt in dieser welt aufwachsen sie
werden geliebt denn man weiß wie ich
danke euch allen
wir haben so eine große familie in der
ganzen welt ich habe tanken und onkel
und ich möchte allen danken
ich möchte sie bitten mich zu vergessen
[Musik]
wusste man wusste dass ich sie alle
nehmen und ich muss auch über den motor
sprechen
in der stadt kannten sie alle
ich liebe euch alle ich mir die
unterstützung
wir sind alle dankbar danke ich möchte
nur sagen dass ich mein bruder ein
bisschen werden
[Musik]
also ich möchte nur sagen dass ich dich
liebe und ich danke gott dass er mir
meinen persönlichen supermann gegeben
hat gott segne euch
es wird tätigkeit geben ich danke allen
die gekommen sind um george zu
unterstützen
er hat die menschen immer mit seinen
worten bewegt bat darum aufzustehen und
in das sind aufrufe gegen ein system das
korrupt und kaputt ist
die gesetze müssen sich ändern
es darf keine hassverbrechen mehr geben
nichts mehr von wegen macht amerika
wieder großartig wanderung amerika
jemals großartig diese polizeibeamten
wählt ich erinnere mich an mein onkel
und das ist alles was ich jetzt noch
habe die erinnerungen
ich kann mich an meine oma ihnen meine
schönste erinnerung an mein onkel war
hier gehalten hat mir den kopf
gestreichelt hat nachdem ich mich
verletzt hatte ja er hat zu mir gesagt
mädchen mit deinem lächeln und deinem
gehirn bist du es weit bringen und daran
kann ich mich erinnern und gewissen
fragen nicht sagte ich damals zu meiner
oma wir wissen noch nicht wie wir es
schaffen aber wir werden das schaffen
und trotz aller schwierigkeiten haben
meine oma und mein opa extrem hart
gearbeitet
nach wege haben nicht funktioniert
amerika es ist zeit dass wir unsere art
ändern unseren weg verändern
es muss gerechtigkeit und frieden geben
in unserer stadt wird es immer liebe
geben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich nach
meiner nichte noch sagen soll dem sie
hat alles gesagt ich war mitten in der
nacht auf denkt an mein bruder
zuerst konnte ich es gar nicht glauben
aber jetzt verstehe ich aber erst danach
seine mutter rief wusste ich sie ist
genau da und hielt ihre hand auf jede
mutter weiß das aber er rief ich kann
nicht dass ich nicht hat mika jetzt
durch gerechtigkeit für meinen bruder
für meinen großen bruder für big floyd
jetzt kennt wohl jeder
wer alle auf der ganzen welt werden sich
an ihn erinnern und er wird die welt
verändern
[Musik]
meine mutter wenn sie heute hier wäre
würde ich mir sicher dass sie auf diesem
dach liegen wurde und zu ihm wollte war
eine wirkliche mutter wird sich niemals
weg reißen nicht verlassen
ich liebe euch alle für die
unterstützung
guten tag ich bin der sportdirektor
ich habe ihn am college kennen gelernt
als am college war und wir haben in den
parks trainiert und viele veranstaltet
wir haben gegen viele college gespielt
waren wichtiger spieler
man wird man fragte mich wer ist ein
großer spieler und ich sagte das war
er hat etliche spiele spielt auch mit
anderen und er hat dafür ein college
stipendium bekommen und und ich habe ein
grundstück hier sichergestellt um ein
george floyd sportzentrum zu errichten
ich habe auf der ganzen welt
unterstützung dafür bekommen und jemand
sagte mir ja wir können dafür die
gebäude zur verfügung stellen
wir haben vor den spielen die brüche in
der bibel immer gelesen und zwei möchte
ich vorstellen
unser bürgermeister hat gesagt dass
heute george wright tag ist ich möchte
sprüche kapitel 6 vorlesen
nun das kann ich in bezug auf wird auf
jeden fall nachvollziehen so behandeln
wir einander uns mangelt es an uns
mangelt es an menschlichkeit an empathie
wir sollten dafür sorgen dass alle
menschen gleich behandelt werden so dass
george floyds tod nicht umsonst war
vielen dank an sie alle
zu hören wie hier alle menschen über
befreit sprechen in dieser kirche
das ist sehr bewegend ich danke allen
ich jeden tag jeden tag werden wir sein
leben jetzt im himmel feiern und wir
alle in dieser kirche die tollen
mitglieder des stadtrates vielen dank
ich möchte ihnen danken haben uns alle
in den letzten tagen und wochen
unterstützt auf der ganzen welt sie
haben lieben alle wir leben alle
zusammen wir werden es gemeinsam
schaffen
ich möchte allen danken die heute
hierher gekommen sind
sein leben zählt black lies meter
sein tod war nicht umsonst was man sein
name zunächst möchte ich gott loben dass
ich im leben die chance hatte mein
bruder kennenzulernen
mein mir meinen ersten job im
sicherheitsbereich hat er mir gegeben er
war ein freund ein mentor ein vater ein
basketballspieler wollte war ein
footballspieler vor allem bei ein mensch
[Musik]
und alt die herausforderungen und
schwierigkeiten die wir durchmachen
müssen
und da war er ein vorbild
ich werde weiterhin etwas sagen ich
werde mich äußern ich werde kämpfen und
weiterkämpfen wissen sie es ist ein
großes glück wienberg kennenlernen im
leben und
aber ein engel ein bruder
wenn man das böse hast aber das gute
liebt und mein bruder war ein vertreter
des guten und sie
man kann nichts schlimmes über ihn sagen
zu mir denn ich kann gewinnen
und wenn sie ihn auch händlern wissen
sie was ich hier meine kämpfe für meinen
bruder die familie kämpft für mein
bruder
danke danke an die familie
wir werden dich nicht im stich lassen
kleiner bruder wir stehen zu dir
dem sie auf und kreisen sie gott preisen
sie seine familie meinem fahrer möchte
ich sagen ich liebe sie ich liebe herr
bürgermeister george freut
jeder der hier für die highschool
football gespielt hat steht steht auf
[Musik]
richtiger amerikaner jeden tag blut
schweiss er was die tränen wenn es
draußen heiß war
doch niemals hatte sich beschwert
nicht ein einziges mal wer ohne sünde
ist das meiste den ersten stein
ich höre viel gerede von manchen leuten
mein bruder diesem an männer die auf
seinem hals standen haben uns jemanden
gehabt der großartig werde er sich nie
beschwert hat
er war ein bruder für uns alle er hat
sich immer für uns eins eingesetzt er
war für jeden da hat jeden geschützt
ich möchte ihnen allen folgen sagen er
war erstens ein mensch ich konnte montag
nach nicht schlafen ich wusste nicht wie
so als ich aufwachte habe ich das ganze
szene gesehen und das tat uns allen weh
wir brauchen in dieser welt moment ist
liebe wenden sie sich ihren nachbarn zu
und sagen sie ihm oder ihr dass die
senioren das brauchen wir sehen wie sie
sich fühlen
george sagte mir dass er mich liebt er
sagte allen menschen dass er sie liebt
so war george wright und deswegen lieben
wir ihnen wenn sie ihn liefen und kanten
sie werden immer job sein
ich bin george wright sie sind george
wright gott sagt zu ihm gut gemacht dort
leute
er befindet sich nun in gottes schutz
es geht ihm gut ich möchte ihnen sagen
amerika bleibt positiv
und gott sieht wie so viele menschen
hier zusammen kommen aus
unterschiedlichen hintergründen wegen
der liebe für george iv leute sind wir
hier zusammen
aber es nie wie lange man noch hat der
schlüssel ist liebe ich liebe euch alle